we need to understand that china is our
enemy numero uno that's for sure
but
i don't want to sacrifice domestic
you know peace and tranquility for
better international
trade warfare with china meaning
okay trump may be better on china but
will he help bridge the gap domestically
i've been pretty outspoken that i i hope
in 2024
desantis is at the head of the ticket
trump doesn't run and we can get a young
energetic charismatic strong leader in
the white house
as as someone who has voted for biden i
would 100 percent vote for someone like
desantis
and my fear is trump will do the same
old rubble rousing play to his base
beat biden you know i have there's
people i don't think this will happen
they are convinced i had an argument
there's a family member of mine they're
like if trump gets elected every single
democrat is going to jail like what are
you talking about this is not going to
happen
because it's going to and i'm arguing
i'm arguing craziness but this is why
what trump has done the divisiveness
side of things yeah so
it will i give trump credit for how he's
handled china for sure has he made
mistakes with that yeah possibly as well
but
i don't want to sacrifice domestic peace
but before going after china sometimes
you
[Music]
sometimes you have to you know let me
explain
um
let me explain i had a i had a meeting
with a bunch of our guys corporate
executives uh in dallas that's when i
was in dallas we had our annual carrier
meeting and i got up and i said you know
what's one of my biggest concerns about
hiring
wholesalers or hiring
uh executives from the insurance
industry that i've been on for 20 30
years or just executives period that
have a nice resume
so you know what's my biggest concern
everybody's like what's your biggest
concern i said they're professional
hide-and-go-seek champions
what do you mean
i said wholesalers are the best at
acting like they're working hard but
they're not
i said executives have figured out the
formula how to use a system to not work
their best
most executives that you hire today
their best years are behind them the
challenge you have
is hiring an executive that's still in
the hunt that's got so much pride
that wants to get in and get the job
done most people just want to come in
and send a nice email send a nice report
show some numbers brag about it and come
ask for a raise and get their bonus
that's all they want to do with the
lowest amount of energy
output to put into it that's
the dna of most executive uh i hate this
and by the way that's eighty percent of
them okay eighty percent and you've
hired dozens and dozens and dozens of
manufacturers yeah i've hired many of
them so you'll never know until you hire
them you work with them for six months
to say this guy's way too political oh
my gosh he's just playing a politics
camp to get everybody on this side this
guy's a worker this guy's a freaking
beast this guy's going to get the job
done that guy is just doing enough job
to get the commission and that's it
they're going to go home that person's
sick every single week something's going
on every single week they need two days
off three days out four days off and
it's ongoing right they've played
they've learned how to play these cards
somebody taught him these bad habits
someone taught him these bad habits
what's the point
here's a point
sometimes you need a son of a [ __ ] to
get the job done
sometimes you need a bmf the other day i
got a text from a guy saying i'm here
with dan fry i think dan fry i don't
know if you remember dan fry the ufc guy
that used to fight is that his name dan
fry f-r-y-e
if you've ever seen this infamous fight
between the two giants he's fighting a
chinese monstrous don fry can you pull
up his picture so people know who he is
i don't know if you know what this guy
is no
if you follow ufc back in the days like
15 years ago this guy was a guy that was
probably one of the most feared men look
at that
stache that guy monster is who he was
right he sends me a message with this
guy oh he was on rogan david that guy's
giving you a run for your money by the
mustache dude he looks like tom selleck
yeah he does look like he looks like tom
selleck times three he looks like he ate
three times it's like any mom's selling
i just look just like that yeah i
believe we totally believe you we
totally believe you but you know uh
sends me a message saying hey i'm
hanging out with this guy for christmas
you know what i said to him i said
that's a qualified bmf yeah okay and you
know how masvidal won the bmf uh baddest
mother you know
etc okay
america kind of needs a bmf as a
president today as much as everybody
said
we need somebody that's
non-controversial i need somebody like
joe biden look how much more life are
peaceful
look how much more we're at peace right
now so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you